what does that rebuilding process look
like for somebody who's trapped in
depression and Suicidal Thoughts I've
been there a lot in my life especially
before my car accident my teenage years
the first woman I ever loved we had a
big breakup and that breakup sent me
down in depression and suicidal planning
it's tough to dispense advice to people
other than get help and I'll share why
because that time in my life I had so
many people coming up to me you know my
friends would come into my dorm room
let's go do something and you just the
hope is lost and what people I think
make the mistake of trying to do is hype
people up everything's gonna be okay
you're gonna be great and what people
need who are suicidal is serious
psychological intervention they need to
seek support and help and outside of
that when they do get that support the
first thing a great therapist is going
to do outside of the emotional
reflection work of why are you here and
what has caused this sort of pattern for
you they're going to get you starting to
get some momentum the most important
thing is when you are super down
outside of finding that emotional
reasoning for where you are is to start
getting momentum because with momentum
comes hope with momentum comes
motivation with momentum comes uh you
know that feeling that there's a reason
for tomorrow and so it's as simple as
just saying okay what are three things
I'm going to do today
and I don't mean that like a lot of
personal development guys would say like
what are your three big goals for the
day I'm like dude sometimes that first
goal is shh I'm gonna shower today
I'm really in shower today
uh I'm gonna walk to the library
and come home
and that's all they got
like literally that's all they got
and you gotta honor that struggle when
you're in that place like know that
where you're at it is okay that you're
there and now you're gonna need help and
now you're gonna have to set up some
daily practices just every day win a
little bit not like win your dreams not
like Crush through goals not like being
badass not like no
momentum man you know most of the guys
I've dealt with in that position who
were suicidal outside of their
therapeutic work I said the most
important thing you can do is win the
morning
just win the morning man I think that's
true for all of us even high performers
like I if I don't have my morning
routine game I feel you know out of
sorts
um so I think it's true for everybody
you gotta own your morning you got to
win it because that starts and sets up
everything else I know you you believe
that as well like people need that
discipline those routines that will help
the rest of their day go better
um and
I don't want to ever be flippant with
the advice to people who are dealing
with that situation outside of get some
help
get some momentum and be okay if that
momentum is really small
because it will build trust that that
momentum builds and trusts those gloomy
and bad dark days trust that those are
going to be there
they'll get less and less and less as
you learn how to cope but they're going
to be there the only thing you're
missing is momentum this is one of the
most frustrating things with
entrepreneurs because you've got the
heart you've got the soul you've got the
desire to serve you know you're capable
of more you see these people doing great
things you say why why can't that be me
I've got everything I've got all the
tools why am I not having more success
when I see all these other people
winning because you don't have momentum
knowing alone is not enough watching
this video is not enough researching
going to conferences events it's not
enough it gives us this temporary high
it's so fun to think about where we
could be and what we could do when
living in dream mode of the things that
we want to create how That's so exciting
right but until you start actually doing
something and so you start going through
that little fear Zone to start actually
creating nothing happens and this is one
of the great missions of my life is
trying to get heart-centered
entrepreneurs with a cause you want to
serve and just getting you out of the
Starting Gate and then just helping you
stay consistent on the thing those two
things from idea to just doing something
and then finding a way to stay
consistent if you did that if you did
that's all you're missing if you did
that your life will be dramatically
different the people you're going to
serve the the amount of income you're
gonna make the life you can provide for
yourself and your family the the mass
massive just flow of goodness you're
going to create for the world will be
totally different you will be a totally
different person one year from today if
you did those simple things the only
thing you're missing is momentum the
only thing you're missing is momentum I
promise you
I look at my YouTube channel and
everything that we've done here and man
it took me so long to get going it took
me so long to get out of my head it took
me so long to get comfortable making
videos no matter how much people told me
just press record and just do it it's
still it's still that voice inside my
head is like well I'm so awkward in
front of the camera and I don't know
what I'm gonna say and I I'm trying to
memorize my script and what camera
should I find and all of the things that
we tell ourselves are important that
aren't
you know if you look at my growth on
YouTube the first five years was so slow
the first five years was so incredibly
slow because I started and stopped and
started and stopped and started and
stopped and convinced myself of why I
couldn't do it and my whole intent with
this is to try to shake you to say don't
waste five years like I did because in
the second five years that's when my
channel started to really blow up and
grow and that's when I started to see
the impact and see the growth and see
the see the the money coming in all of
it it started to take off because I just
started creating a lot more momentum I
stopped watching my videos and reminding
myself of how much I sucked and just
kept going
so how do you do it how do you start
building momentum how do you start
taking the thing that you know is inside
you that you know you're capable of more
that you don't want to be stuck in the
same spot one year from today it's like
I need to finally make something happen
right is that you are you ready for that
how do we actually start getting the
momentum in our lives I'm going to give
you three strategies okay
number one
your morning routine has to be on point
as I said on top of this video
successful people don't wake up and say
yes oh my gosh what a day I'm gonna take
over this is gonna be amazing I woke up
and I was tired I don't remember what
day it is and I got lines in my face and
I'm struggling out of bed right
everybody wakes up the same way
don't judge yourself and feel like you
suck because you woke up and you were
tired and didn't feel super motivated to
go off and crush your day right that's
everybody that's me that's Brandon
bershard That's Tony Robbins it's Oprah
Winfrey everybody the difference is the
routine to set you up for success and
chances are if you watch this video you
already have a morning routine right
you're an achiever you have a morning
routine so I want to take this to the
next level for people with a morning
routine because your morning routine is
probably not working for you most of the
world doesn't have a morning routine
most of the world wakes up like an
accident most of the world wakes up
falls into their phone and starts
responding to other people's emergencies
right that's probably not you at least
not every day you might be 50 50 but you
probably have a morning routine
what's the value of a morning routine
the value of our morning routine
is to get you the feeling of bold
confidence and courage
that's why you haven't worn your team
it's supposed to help you go and win the
day
if you don't feel confident bold and
courage at the end of your morning
routine then you've done something wrong
either the morning routine itself is
broken and you need to add something in
or you just didn't do it with enough
intent
most Achievers here's what's happening I
want you to do a fair self-assessment
and audit of your morning routine most
Achievers what you're doing is you have
your list of things that you're supposed
to do in the morning and you probably
hit those maybe 70 to 80 of the time
but most of the time of those 70 80 you
just check in the box
you said you're gonna do this okay I'm
gonna work out I'm gonna watch this
video I'm gonna read this book and
listen to this podcast so I'm going to
whatever but you're not intentional with
it having this video on was I created
the espresso channel here to try to
support you to try to be there for your
morning routine to give you a shot of
espresso every day to start your day
let's go but if you're watching this
video while you're making your bed and
brushing your teeth and and looking over
your email and browsing through social
media guess what happens
you're not getting the feeling
you could check the box and say yep
watch the video but if you don't feel
courageous and bold
you didn't do it with enough intent you
didn't do it with enough Focus you were
distracted all the way through and so
this is what happens with Achievers in a
morning routine is you check the box for
all the things you said you were going
to do but you don't feel any better than
you did when you woke up
and if you don't feel any better than
you did when you woke up you're not
going to go off and win the day
so the most important part of a morning
routine whether it takes you five
minutes or three hours
is getting the feeling so do an honest
self-assessment
do you feel bold at the end of your
morning routine and if not what you need
to add in there so that you do
or do you need to go back and just do
your morning routine with actual
intention because if you'd started your
day with the thing that made you feel
bold powerful Unstoppable confident your
life will dramatically change when
you're from today I promise you so
number one is you have to fix your
morning routine
number two to get more momentums how do
we get more momentum in our lives number
two
is to go from idea to action
start to teach yourself that you come up
with great ideas normally what happens
when you get an idea what happens
normally when you get an idea
we get excited maybe you tell your
friends about it your family or you're
just researching and planning and
brainstorming you get excited about it
and then what happens is this little
voice inside your head tells you all the
reasons why you can't do it you can't do
it because of this because of that
because you don't have the connections
the money the skills the education the
family or whatever there's always some
reason and so the combat that you try to
do more research and more planning and
more more understanding to try to have
the perfect plan and this was me guys I
lost a 40 million deal when I was in my
20s because I was trying to be too
perfect because I was afraid and all I
really need to do is get more momentum
so you have to teach yourself to go from
idea to action when you get that idea
trust that the idea came to you for a
reason trusted the intention is good is
the intention good is the intention to
serve is the intention to help yes
perfect action something today has to
happen today use your best energy on
creating some kind of momentum in
Perfect action
versus trying to have the perfect plan
and then you wake up tomorrow and you've
already talked yourself down and you
can't do it so number one is you have to
fix your morning routine number two is
you have to go from idea to action and
then number three is to change your
environment
the more that you are around the people
who are doing the thing that you want to
do the more that that starts to seep
into YouTube
it's why I have so many channels because
there's always content hopefully out
there for you you might say yeah but I
don't know anybody Evan who's successful
I I can't hang out with Brandon burchard
or Oprah or whoever I don't know these
people great
I know Brandon but I know I don't know
Oprah
and I didn't know Brendan when I first
got started how did I learn from the
videos about having videos around me
every day having these people on the
wall behind me we even wearing this
hoodie when I feel like Batman putting
it on every morning makes a big
difference to start to change your
environment to be around the people who
are thinking the way that you want to
think the people around you right now
are influencing you to stay where you
are
might think about the people who you
hang out with now that old expression if
you are the average of the five closest
people to you yeah great so who are the
five closest people to you they are
influencing your thinking and they're
keeping you stuck where you are right
now and if you love where you are right
now great but if you know you want to do
more then you have to start to change
what starts to influence you
consistently not these one-off moments
of inspiration and boldness but
consistency that's the thing that's
missing you might have this one day
that's amazing oh my gosh I can do
anything and what happens you wake up
tomorrow and all that energy is gone
it's a start and stop and start and stop
and start and stop that is holding you
back
so be strategic with your environment to
think about how do I start to surround
myself with the people with the videos
with the books with the podcast with the
physical environment that make me feel
like I can do more that you can do more
fix those three things fix your morning
routine go for my day to action and fix
your environment do that because the
only thing you're missing is momentum
the only thing you have you have the
heart you have the care you have the
desire to serve you have great ideas
inside you
other people are winning with inferior
ideas with less of a desire to serve
than you do and they're winning and the
only difference is they got started and
they're going the only thing you're
missing is momentum
I can't wait to see you actually start
to apply it to make massive change in
your life and your business also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've
got just for this video the worksheet
will highlight all of the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
I remember when I was going to start my
business and I I really wanted to be
good at it you know I was trying to
become an author and a speaker and do
these types of videos and do some online
training for people on the topics of
motivation and marketing and you know
some all these people are saying well
Brandon you know you may or may not be
successful with that you're you know
blah blah and I thought it's a weird
thing it's not like there's a trait of
successful people you look across
history and successful people it's not
they're not from a given background they
don't come from a specific economic
stature they're not in a position where
you know they're they're one demographic
or another Democrat I mean it's all over
I mean we've got thousands of collective
years of history people succeed some
people do some people don't and I think
it more comes down to how do we manage
our mind and how do we manage our days
and I think that there's a difference
between successful people and
unsuccessful people in the way they
particularly think about
approaching something new you know I
think unsuccessful people when they have
a big dream and they start thinking
about what is going to be required to
accomplish that dream they get very
limiting in their beliefs about
themselves and what's possible and
specifically they say three types of
things you know the first thing they
often say is well you know I don't know
how to do that
so they stop they say you know I I don't
have those things so they stop
or they say I don't know you know I'm
not like those people I'm not like that
and so they stop
but successful people have a different
way they have the same thing everybody
dreams you dream I dream successful
people dream people just starting out
everybody dreams everyone has a vision
everyone if they can just take five
minutes today and think about their
lives we could all come up with ways to
improve our lives and reach another
level of success joy happiness
achievement contribution fulfillment
Soul you know we can all Elevate but the
challenge is that the unsuccessful
people they keep stopping when they
think of what they currently know have
or are
but successful people say well I want to
do that but I don't know how to do that
but instead of stopping they say well
then my job is to go learn that
they take their current limitation
and they put it on their agenda as a job
to do as a thing to figure out a thing
to make happen instead of saying well I
don't have that they say well then my
job is to go build that or I'm not like
that then they say well then my job is
to go become more of that become that
person who could accomplish those things
you know when I was starting to do
online marketing for the first time and
and I don't know if how much of my story
you know but when I started doing online
marketing I was literally bankrupt and I
went from a place of bankruptcy to the
point where I really committed to
becoming successful at it and in 18
months I made 4.8 million dollars 4.6
collected I mean it was just like a huge
leap right in in indifference from
bankrupt to multi-millionaire and a span
of 18 months
but what made that breakthrough wasn't
that I had new opportunities it wasn't
that I had new technologies it wasn't
like wow there's the internet now those
things were already there it went I went
from this level of thinking to this
level of thinking I used to say well I I
don't know how to build a web page
so I said agenda figure out how to build
a web page and I spent hours and hours
and hours at nights on weekends from my
job figuring out how to do that and I
said well I don't have one of those
lists you know I don't have any
subscribers nobody knows who I am so I
said job go build a list go get
subscriber go add value and content out
of the marketplace and they'll come I
mean just keep putting stuff out there
and I also didn't say oh my gosh well I
have that dream I can't have that
because I'm not like that because I
wasn't a public speaker I didn't know
how to do video I wasn't like well I'm
not one of those video people well I'm
not a public speaker so I said you know
what I have to go learn that art I have
to go become a better speaker a better
Communicator I have to go become more
confident I have to go become a person
capable of doing these things I have to
change myself to get there I can't wait
for circumstances to change so I can
have my dream then our dreams would
never happen we have to get to the point
of maturity in our lives where we say
Okay 2 two things are going to change my
life something new is going to come into
my life and make me lucky and blessed
and maybe I can't count on that forever
and maybe now instead I have to
consciously design my life and say okay
now if I want to change if I want my
dream something new has to come from me
I'm going to become a better person I'm
going to become a person who is more
optimistic who is more confident who is
more driven not because I am that now
but because we can grow
that you can become the type of person
who needs to who you need to be to
achieve your ideal life you can start
today living from your highest ideals
your highest sense of self your
strongest sense of self you don't need
permission you don't need a guy like me
to look at the video camera and say you
have now permission but if you've been
waiting for it you have permission it's
like at some point in your life you just
say okay I have permission to become my
best self and by becoming your best self
you start to achieve your best things
you start to contribute better things
you start to become a better human being
you can do that now today so next time
you're thinking about a big dream don't
think about the things that well I don't
know how to do that and stop think I
don't know how so set it up on your
calendar to go learn those things I
don't have that then set it up step by
step to go build that I'm not like that
then set it up step by step to go
develop those skill sets and those
competencies so you can become that and
ultimately you can achieve that dream
it's there it's waiting for you don't
stop now I know you all have big goals
Big Dreams big aspirations just like I
do you've got Ambitions to become an
amazing person to build your career to
create contribute to give to be an
awesome human being but all of that is
impossible without great habits set up
if you don't have routine and structure
set up in a way that will keep you on
track then you'll you'll fall off and
and having new goals without new habits
is kind of like you know having a new
car without wheels you know the habits
are the wheels they're the things that
make you able to achieve the goals so
you got to have good habits but the
challenge for most people isn't that
knowledge I mean you know you need to
have good habits it's you can't keep the
Habit going right have you ever started
it the new year you're going to get
healthier and you start that habit of
working out on a more regular basis and
then it goes away or you say you know
I'm going to be more kind and more
patient and more awesome to my partner
my lover and you start being nice for
two or three days and then on the fourth
day you're a jerk you know and you're
like why what happened I said I was
gonna be nicer it's that you didn't set
up the most important thing you needed
to maintain a habit so what's the
biggest secret I've learned in almost 20
years in this field it's so simple but
most people don't have it it's called
trigger moments
you have to set up trigger moments to
activate your habits what do I mean by
that well let's say you want to become a
better person you know you want to
become more kind more patient more
loving with people now you can just set
that intention or write that down in
your vision in your journal or set up on
a vision board that you look at once in
a while but in day-to-day life it's not
enough you need things to trigger you to
remind you to be that particular kind of
person right it's almost like if you
could have a little angel speaking in
your ear all day long to tell you what
to do and how to be you'd obviously
become better well that makes sense well
let's use that idea let's use that idea
by setting up alarms on our phones that
trigger us to do the very things we need
to do this can be so basic you're going
to laugh and then also tell you how I've
literally taught this to Fortune 50 CEOs
and they said it was the one thing that
changed their life the most dramatically
so let's start with this let's have a
goal in mind let's say you want to
become more present and calm throughout
the day again you could write that down
on a journal I'm going to more present
and calm you could meditate in the
morning say today don't be more present
and calm and you're you could you could
start out with good intentions but those
fall apart without a trigger moment set
up throughout the day to remind you that
so what if you did this what if you just
set up on your phone three alarms during
the day with a label
that said
close your eyes
[Music]
take 10 deep breaths in
remind yourself to be calm
so let's say you're going through your
day it's crazy right it's 10 a.m and
also Bing your phone goes off you look
down and it says close your eyes take 10
deep breaths and then again it happens
at two o'clock and again it happens at
six pm and again it happens at 8 pm
what's gonna happen you always look at
your phone don't you it's going to go
throughout the day you're going to
forget and the funniest thing is I've
had so many people do this worldwide
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people I've taught to do
this hundreds of thousands and they tell
me all the time that changed everything
and you'll think once you set it up that
the next day you you'll you'll forget
about it no that alarm will go off you
forgot you set the dang alarm there it
goes off in your face you're like all
right I'm trying to be calmer and more
present close my eyes take 10 deep
breaths re-ground myself here we go
it you can't do it once a day you have
to have moments throughout the day that
trigger you to enact the new Behavior I
know this makes sense to you but it's a
challenge for a lot of people because
they never set those things up so what
if you did it with an alarm
so for example for me on the opposite
Spectrum I don't want to just be calmer
and more present I Want More Energy
throughout the day so here's what I do
one of my big trigger moments is every
time my butt hits a chair I don't care
if I'm on a plane or I was like where
we're shooting here I I wrote a lot of
my books here I wrote the motivation
Manifesto here I wrote The Charge here
and if I'm going to write my butt hits
the chair I grab my phone I open the
timer and I set 50 minutes
now at 50 minutes the timer goes it
starts buzzing and I look at that and I
go oh that's my trigger to get energy so
I stand up I go get some water I take a
glass of water drink it down I do some
stretches and I do some exercise just
really briefly or I'll go for a walk
whatever it is but I'll do something
that usually takes just two to five
minutes then I'll sit back down I'll set
that 50 minute alarm and I'll work
and what that does is every 50 minutes
it triggers me to change how I'm
physically moving it changes my
attention so that throughout the day I'm
continually refreshed so I never have
that two three four o'clock time where
I'm like ah you know why because I've
triggered my day so that my energy is
maintained throughout the day makes
sense right at least could be as simple
as let's say you want to be healthier in
your life okay let's set up some trigger
moments for you in this way let's say
every time you drop off the kids on the
way back to the house you stop at the
grocery store and get some fresh produce
that's just a trigger it's like okay did
one thing drop kids off now tied to that
triggered from that action drop kids off
is go to health food store or let's say
you want to get healthier in the morning
one of the easiest ways to help people
maintain a better exercise program is
this
set a trigger you wake up in the morning
your first action is to drink water
put your exercise shoes on it might get
dressed if you were naked just saying so
you get dressed put your shoes on you go
downstairs or you go to the gym and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions nothing interrupts those
actions that's the action and you have
to have those set up one of my other
favorite trigger moments to set up is
door frame triggers what do you remember
that when you walk into a new room
to have a psychological trigger go off
in your mind that you've associated with
that door frame so let me give you an
example if I walk into my house at night
after if I've been working all day and
I'm going to walk in I'm gonna see my
lady I have it so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house three
words repeat off immediately in my mind
because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said three words said
the three words and I did this so many
times and now when I walk through a door
my mind automatically triggers those
three words and I remember to be those
three words so what words would you love
to have describe you as a person that
you would be happy if that was how
people described you what would those
words be have those and now set them up
in your life I teach Executives to do
this as well I have them have a door
frame trigger when they walk into their
office in the morning as soon as they
walk through that door frame they have
boom three words go through their mind
about how they want to be perceived as a
leader I haven't set up another door
frame every time they walk into a
meeting into the conference room when
they walk through the doors of the
conference room they have another three
words that trigger off for them and it
just reminds them how to be
so these are Big crazy things a lot of
people think they have to completely
change their life what would change your
life completely is setting up more
trigger moments and associations that
when you see something you do this that
when this action is taken then that
happens that when you uh have the
opportunity to set up alarms on your
phone you set them up so that you're
interrupted in your everyday life to
remind yourself to stick to the habits
to stick to the intention you do that
enough on a continual basis you'll find
yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes
you have to be all in and it's the
hardest thing to do because if it fails
then you can feel like a failure
um you know I think of this idea of
performance necessity two stories kind
of come to mind one is I was working
with an Olympic gold medalist Sprinter
and we're in the tunnel and we're going
out and he's talking about the
competition and we get out to the blocks
and I said uh he was really worried
about the competition I said well how do
you even gauge like who who who's going
to win you know in in his particular
race people are winning but by you know
one one hundredths of a second tenths of
a second I mean these are really close
Sprints and I said well how how do you
know I said who would you even bet on
and he says you know I would bet on the
guy
who gets down at the blocks
gets himself settled looks at the finish
line then says
I gotta do this
for my mom
and I was like oh
that's good his performance necessity in
that is it's necessary for him to win
that race for his mom
um I think of you know when I started
my career and I really decided to go all
in with writing and online training this
is like 2000 probably six uh I'd gone
broke completely bankrupt and failed I
left my corporate job I had this cushy
kind of corporate job as a consultant
good job left it to write and I didn't
know how to make it as a writer I want
to do seminars workshops didn't know how
to do that so I was pretty much a hot
mess ran out of money I got nothing to
my name nothing kind of no positive
prospects no one's calling me accept the
guys who want the money
and um
one night I'm writing and the
apartment's so small on the bed I had a
all you know what my bills my vision
boards all my research all my journals
like the bed was basically the desk the
extended desk and my lady comes in
Denise and she walks past me but she
sees I'm like trying to write so it
doesn't want to disturb me she goes
crawls under the covers of the bed
and I'm just typing kind of casually
typing away
and I look over
and
I see my woman
sleeping under my bills
and it was just like
you know because none of us want to see
our you know
our families suffer because we are
not performing sure
and um
I was just like
how to figure this out
and I'm telling you I wrote more that
night than any night in my entire life
next day I wrote more than ever that
birth life's golden ticket which became
a bestseller and in you know 18 months
later because I was like I'm gonna
figure out this online thing I mean
throughout marketing I'm gonna figure
out how to teach I'm gonna how to train
and get paid for it because I've never
really been paid for those things I said
I'm going to figure out this industry
and I'm gonna make it 18 months later
after her
crawling under the bills I made 4.6
million dollars Jesus online
Total Transformation people like how did
you do it I'm like she gave me and she
was my necessity I was not going to let
my woman be in that situation
um and she believed in me she supported
me she married me and uh you know but
that was she was my drive
and the second part was I went all in
with my identity I said I am going to be
a great writer
I am going to be one of the greatest
online trainers there ever was
you know as you said in the intro now
we've graduated over 2 million people
have taken our online courses video
series now I don't think it would have
happened if I hadn't had the guts and
maybe
the no other choice right to say this is
who I'm going to be and I'm going to
build into that
and it's necessary for me to become that
person so let's go you know the first
way you should not compare yourself to
others is in terms of especially today
their fans their Fame their followership
right Their audience never do that in my
industry that's very very popular to do
and it's ruined a lot of people's lives
who don't ever rise up to serve because
they think they're not popular enough
you know it's like that you write your
first book and you don't have as many
sales as other people and you think oh
well I don't have the audience or you go
to someone's fan page and you see oh my
gosh look at their followership look at
how many Instagram followers they have
how many Twitter followers they have and
and because you see them so big you
think oh I could never be that so you
don't even begin and a lot of people do
that they say well I'm not that big so
they never start but as I always say you
know what no matter how small you start
start something that matters begin it if
I began my career looking at my heroes
looking at a Wayne Dyer or a Tony
Robbins or a Marianne Williamson a
Deepak Chopra a Jim Rohn back in the day
or or looking at people like OG mandinos
who'd sold millions of books or or even
the famous books that you saw millions
and millions and millions of copies if I
gauge myself to that and thought that
was the expectation I would never begin
so you can't expect to start out with
tons of people some some people say to
me all the time well Brennan it's so
easy for you because you got millions of
people on your email list you have
millions of people on Facebook and and
tens of Millions on YouTube I say it
doesn't make it any harder for me I
still show up and shoot this video and
the reason I have the followers and the
fans and the audience is because I
showed up and I started when there was
only one dude 10 dudes 100 dudes a
thousand dudes watching us my first
seminar that I ever did we we only had
22 people in the room and now we fill up
seminars nine times a year often from
people from 46 countries around the
world fly in paying thousands of dollars
a ticket and what did I do I I started
with 22 people in a room and most of
those people didn't even pay and every
time the the guy walked in with with
water I counted him as one of those 22
years like I I had no followership it
was never about how big you start it's
that you start and you get big by
staying at it because what people do is
they put out the first video they write
the first book they they try their first
thing online and nobody follows nobody
watches and they quit they get
disappointed
and where there's disappointment there
was too high of as an expectation on
achievement versus learning versus
process versus beginning what you want
to do is never be disappointed and the
way that you're never disappointed is
you understand every single step counts
every single step is learning every
single step gets you going but if you
have the aspiration or the the attention
that's only focused on their
followership and meeting that you'll
never begin don't compare your
followership to anybody else's instead
just compare your work ethic be there
show up work get it done the second
thing I want you to compare yourself to
is other people's achievements that
means their wealth their sales number
their uh big house their big car their
whatever else you know their fancy
clothes they're whatever they got don't
look at other people's achievements and
what they have because if you do that
it's also you think well I'm not famous
enough and then you think well I'm not
lucky enough bless enough rich enough
whatever your excuse becomes you gotta
be very very very careful of that and I
know you know that but lately have you
been looking at other people's stuff and
feeling demoralized because of that well
I you know they had a silver spoon in
their mouth or they're so lucky those
types of things stop us from even trying
because we feel like the game is unfair
well it's not most wealthy people
especially all the billionaires I've met
I've been blessed to meet lots of them
and Coach a few of them the mega Stars I
get to work with the Olympians I get to
work with the highest achieving people
in the world they it's not luck and most
of them didn't have unbelievable lucky
family connections what they did is they
hustled they worked they built it and
even if they started a little more
abundant than other people
they outlasted their peers who also
started out abundant because they gave
they worked they struggled through and
we got to keep going
the third thing don't compare yourself
ever in terms of looks appearances
Beauty you know I I know if you're
somebody who opens up those fashion
magazines or their celebrity gossip
magazines you're always looking oh she's
cuter than me oh he's better looking and
then again you have the excuse as soon
as you compare yourself to other people
you have the excuse to never begin you
have the reason to be demoralized I mean
there's if I looked across YouTube and I
started doing my episodes or my videos
or or iTunes or podcasts you know I
would have never begun because you got
all these people out there they're like
they're amazing they look so good they
sound so good and I sucked I couldn't
talk like this before now as you know
all of our videos and every episode I've
ever done has been unscripted no notes I
got nothing I'm looking right at you
there's nothing in front of me I just go
and they're all in one single take
majority of them I think 99 are one take
and that came from practice where for
years and years in years years and years
and years I I tried to be able to just
speak extemporaneously without using
notes without using a script I taught
myself to do this and if I'd compared
myself to other people who were so
polished and looking good and every word
was precise I would have never gotten to
where we're at today with literally
hundreds of millions of views and from
our posts to our videos it came because
I didn't worry about the Polish of
looking like everybody else I was just
doing my thing
so what should you compare why should
you be comparing yourself to others for
growth reasons learning reasons I mean
the first reason you should always
compare yourself to others is for
creativity to get ideas not to steal and
not to compare but rather to go oh how
would I do that you know in comparing
yourself to others it brings in
self-awareness to say oh look this is
how I'm distinct this is how I'm
different this is how I could approach
this in a different way if I didn't
research the market I would never know
how I could be different if I didn't
know how it could be different I could
never have a business you cannot build a
business or have a real career or make
any major contribution without
understanding how you're distinct Steve
Jobs knew that when he built the phone
it was different and that thinking
differently is what made him an icon
it's the same for everything that we do
compare so you know it is out there so
you know how you could bring a new
Creative Edge to it second reason to
compare is to compare for vision
because as you get self-awareness and
you understand how you're distinct
sometimes you see someone doing
something amazing and you're like wow I
I got a bigger vision for myself when I
started seeing people posting videos you
know back in 2007 I got a bigger vision
for myself I mean 2007 I saw people
posting longer videos online I thought
wow I never saw myself doing video but
look look at how I'm watching these and
I'm relating with these I got to do some
video and by comparing myself to others
to other people I followed or researcher
read their books and I saw that they had
a podcast I'm like I'm gonna get a
podcast it opened up my vision for the
vehicles the mediums the the ways that I
could serve and give and I want you to
do the same and the last piece the
reason to compare yourself is for growth
there is an amazing amount of talent in
this world and when you see them it
should inspire you to level up it
inspired me to learn how to do video it
inspired me to learn how to speak
extemporaneous and it inspired me to get
over my fears of public speaking and
step on a stage and now it's in front of
thousands and thousands of people to
inspired the world I never I never
thought I could do that but seeing other
people sometimes achieves the remarkable
you get inspired if it's not about if
you can look at someone who's done
something better than you and it
inspires you that means you have
humility and you got a chance
if you look at other people who've
achieved more have more look more feel
good are more amazing than you and you
get bitter or upset that means you're
small and you're destined to smallness
but if you can look at greatness and be
inspired you're on track you're going to
live an extraordinary quality of life
the kind of life that we call the charge
life in our lives
especially when we're being
reactive
information comes in right we're at an
event we're paying attention to how
people treat us
we're studying something we're trying to
learn something and we're just going
about a regular day information is
coming in how people perceive us the
cause and effective events things are
just happening information comes into
the brain from that point the
information immediately
goes into
interpretation
and what this usually means is
interpretation in the fast reactive
thing is safe unsafe good
bad
like it
don't like it recognize it
don't recognize it
been there done that unfamiliar familiar
certain uncertain fear safe all these
things start triggering it's pretty
unconscious and it's pretty fast our
biases come into play it's just that
speed spontaneous reactive part of us
and it's that's not always bad sometimes
it can be good
right sometimes it can be good
interpretation could be that event
that's good for me or that events that's
bad for me but usually it's like a snap
judgment think about that most
most when we're talking about an
unconscious level it's like a snap
judgment automatic like you like her
don't like her feel safe don't feel safe
it's very fast
then the next level and this is not
always linear of course because your
brain is not left brain right brain kind
of methodology your brain's more of a
spider web of interconnectedness that is
something we still don't understand okay
you can study everything in neuroscience
and you might learn something about this
lobe or that that cortex region but then
only to find out that later on a year
later like well actually it seems like
it's also communicating over here it's a
spider web of unbelievable intelligence
that's happening that and everything can
be millisecond hundreds of milliseconds
of transitions between neural networks
it's unbelievably fast unbelievable
capable so this is just for our
understanding it's not necessarily real
world linear like this but what tends to
happen is as information comes in good
bad we also then move it to
a level of well what does this mean to
me
identity
what does this mean to me what does this
either mean to me or what does this say
about me
how does this apply to me
and if we're not conscious here this is
going to be really Troublesome some of
you discovered that yesterday I bet when
you released a few things sometimes we
have these events in our life that we we
take on and we just assume it meant
something about us and we didn't realize
no that's more of a statement about them
than it is about us
right sometimes when you're hurt or
someone was rude to you it had nothing
to do with you raise your hand you
follow
I had nothing to do with you but if
you're not careful you could say
mean person unsafe means I'm bad child
rude Behavior
uncertain about this I must not be long
terrible situation
I feel bad
I can never be safe again
how many follow how this happens
this is why we have to be very very very
observational of our own thoughts and
feelings because how these things get
labeled can really change our lives
forever well imagine like last night I'm
going on the stage right if I if my
identity says I am a public speaker and
it is important for me to be excellent
at this and then I go on stage and I
bomb
what does that say about me as a person
so we've got about 50 years of work in
Psychology the field of psychology
saying do not tie your efforts to your
identity because that risk of
disappointment or rejection you know if
the task fails you shouldn't take that
as as a defining moment in which you'd
say I am a failure
right so that's and that's what you know
psychologists tell us to be wary of
except it turns out that high performers
flipped out on its face and go well
actually
um no I do get bothered if it fails I
really get upset about it I am attached
to the process here I I do care if it
turns out well I mean that's why they
obsess about the details that's why they
care about Excellence is like no one
obsessed about the details or cares
about Excellence unless it means
something to them
and there is a risk the risk is you over
attach
to the process or the outcome
with your identity so that if the
processor outcome goes bad now you feel
bad about yourself as a human and now
you stop your progress
but I also tell people there's a balance
there
I actually wish more people would attach
some identity to what they're doing they
wouldn't go through the motions as much
I mean I think what the world needs less
of is half interested parents who don't
have an identity that says you know what
I'm going to be an excellent parent
I think we have a lot of CEOs or
business people or entrepreneurs who
they've never stepped in and said you
know what
I'm a CEO
I own this business I am responsible for
paying the bills I am responsible for
making the money I'm responsible for all
these people's mortgages who work for me
like they I want them to own the
identity of a CEO because most of them
if you ask them about their identity and
their business they're kind of like you
come to find
they're kind of approaching it like
not even hobbyists
it's like if you want to win your
identity has to be tied into that thing
in which you are trying to succeed at
and give to and that takes a lot of guts
to put yourself all in for something but
who's ever contributed something with
tremendous impact without being all into
it I've never seen it so I think the
message of the book you're right I'll
get some Flack of super a lot of
psychologists say don't don't tell
people to tie more of their Identity or
my friends who are Buddhists will say
but attachment is the form of all
suffering but I didn't have you not read
your spiritual attacks I'm like look out
calm down I've hung out with the Dalai
Lama I'm totally cool
but what I'm trying to tell you is even
the Dalai Lama has a connection with
himself as a spiritual leader his
identity is still there that people you
know assume that you know we have to
release ourselves from having an
attachment to something but I'm like I
think we all want to be present and
engaged fully
in the things that we are doing in our
lives
and that's going to require us to say
psychologically you know what I I
am all in this
that's what I'm about it's the Habit is
generate energy okay not necessarily
have energy create energy create energy
and what they do the way we measure that
was kind of academic mental energy which
is tied to your focus and your stamina
and your ability to manage complex tasks
without too much mental stress number
two is emotional energy
which is just the quality or positive
emotions
and number three is physical energy
High performers are 40 percent more
likely to work out five times per week
then the rest of their peers so that
means the top 15 percent most high
performing people in the world tend to
work out five days per week and that
workout could be defined as you know 45
minute brisk walk or you know hit
intensity or whatever it is but
40 percent more likely that's a huge
finding and what we found is high
performers just have better well-being
and happiness and physical conditioning
than everybody else
um one stunning finding was uh CEOs
senior Executives and business owners
they report expending as much energy
as athletes who are competitive now I
can imagine yeah yeah I kind of I was
surprised by that I would have thought
you know athletes would be ten percent
more I mean the emotional and mental
energy after the decision making the
conversations the big deals the
stakeness yeah there's a lot of energy
it's a lot that's why I mean if you
really want to achieve your dreams you
have to care for your body yeah your
mind that's why all these things you
know finally resonating in the
marketplace because the science of
meditation or taking a break or you know
uh managing your own energy sleep is
everything
um and I think all of that is really
important and we say generate energy
because there's this myth that you know
some people have happiness or they have
it's like no you generate you don't have
happiness you generate it yeah you
create it and so the quality of your
energy you have to create like you and I
both I mean if most of our audience knew
our schedules your schedule the last
five days is like how is Lewis even able
to focus right now and how are you able
to get here and do this as well yeah but
it's because we say well this is our
mission show up man you know there's
plenty of times I gotta imagine you've
walked on the field and you were like
exhausted you know I remember you like
flew down to compete and yeah yeah I
still play with the USA team handball
yeah uh team and a year ago I flew down
to
I remember I did an interview in Miami
and then flew out from Miami and then
went and just went right into training
camp and then played against Brazil
which is like you know Olympic Olympic
qualifiers and yeah got our assets book
but it was fun you know but I had to
have Clarity yeah she would show up even
when I was like oh we're gonna lose yeah
like there's zero chance yeah it was
like the worst team in the NBA playing
like the Warriors and we were just like
we had no chance yeah but I had to show
up and give my best and you have to set
all these routine I mean you know the
amount of routines that Tom Brady has in
his life so that he can generate energy
it's unbelievable stuns most people it's
unbelievable and that's just that's
that's what it takes if you want to take
that level if you don't want to be at
that level you don't have to do it yeah
you don't have to do it I mean everybody
can just like well I'm gonna go you know
hit the Cinnabon but it's like it's
pretty good how do you want to feel at
three o'clock yeah if you want to feel
amazing at three o'clock don't end lunch
with a Cinnabon one of the major major
Keys we found the first High performing
habit is seek clarity
and what we found is one of the
practices that high performers do is
they Define the feeling they're after
and so when we had to explain that and
later talk about it in the energy
chapter we had to differentiate between
feelings and emotions and they are
different emotions tend to be they're
the same yeah like we have they're
physical they're almost always automatic
even though in the brain is creating
associations has ought to happen for us
they just kind of emotion comes up yeah
you're watching a movie and you're just
sad and you're like oh my gosh you know
I'm crying you didn't even have the
tissues ready you're just like you know
uh but the feelings are usually
interpretations that we make of what
that emotion was and how it sticks and
the meaning we give it to it yeah and
the example I used to you know I like to
give and I don't remember if it's in the
book or not honestly because here's
what's happened this book is 400 pages
it was 1481 when I finished baby you
edited it down yes and it was 1481 good
complete like it was like awesome yes
but I was like that's gonna freak people
out so we're publishing a bunch in
academic journals later and then
stripped it down to 400 pages so it's
more readable and fun and orientable so
I can't remember if this one actually
made it in there but
um the example I like to give is if you
and I go to a haunted house yeah which I
love I love them I love them and they
scare me the crap but if you and I walk
around you know you walk around on the
walls in a haunted house someone jumps
out at you yeah you and I are both gonna
jump yes we are emotionally going to
experience fright immediately it's going
to be there right but I might be freaked
out for the next five minutes
and you might be laughing
why it's the meaning and the feeling
that we've defined it as
that's fine for everybody here's the
issue that people have and you have to
be careful about when we start talking
about energy because emotional energy is
real yes and that is look if at six like
we go to the haunted house at you know 5
PM in the afternoon
if at 9 00 PM now you're in your house
you're alone but you're completely safe
and you still feel scared
that's not the haunted houses problem
that is the way that you are defining
and working through your own emotions
you had the emotion of Terror and fear
and you're still experiencing that
feeling that's a mental job
not an emotional job
so your job is to go wow I'm at my house
I've lived here for 10 years I've never
been threatened this house this is a
safe place I gotta redefine the feeling
I want to experience and I work with one
uh an Olympic sprinter gold medalist
Olympic sprinter as a client and this
person's huge breakthrough
in getting better and going from
literally uh one Olympics before not
meddling at all to now gold I said what
made like what was the thing yeah and
one of the things they said to me was I
learned to define the feeling
and I said what do you mean by that and
he basically said you know if if if
there's a bunch of us at the starting
box and we're all in perfect Poise in
perfect condition the one to bet on is
the one that says this is the way I want
to feel in this race right now I know my
emotions are going crazy like my heart's
beating I can hear everybody I'm waiting
for that shot blast I can see my goal I
know how important this is and all these
um like these their emotions are there
yeah but that person is defining the
feeling I'm going to feel centered now
I'm going to get myself in the zone now
even though the anxiety is the emotion
of anxiety is there for all Olympic
level competitors all of them but they
Define that feat that emotion as a
feeling that helps give them a
Performance Edge
and I think that's important too you
know Bruce Springsteen says if he's ever
backstage and doesn't feel like nerves
he's going to hang it up yeah
but that's anxiety he's just defining it
differently it's so simple like when you
get the life is really short and you
felt that before but either by you were
threatened or you've had someone near
dear near and dear die but when you have
that real Essence in you that says life
is short have reverence for it live it
that's a really big thing I got that at
19 and I learned specifically that if we
have a moment of cognition before the
end of our life we tend to ask questions
to evaluate if we're happy
so if I have any impact in the world
it's going to come from that experience
where
I learned that the ultimate lesson is
determine what the questions you're
going to ask at the end of your life are
going to be
find out those questions what will you
ask at the end of your life to evaluate
your life
so that you would know if you were happy
with your life like figure out those
questions
and then live each day
intentionally so you're happy with the
answers at the end for me the answer is
the questions I had were did I live
which I hadn't I hadn't been living my
life I'd been thinking about taking my
life
that I love
no my heart was broken
and I put up all these walls to keep out
other people and I always say you know
sometimes the walls we put up to keep up
the bad guys prevent the good guys from
getting in and suddenly in our own
self-protection we block out the very
thing we want which is connection
and I learned that I would ask did I
matter
you know 22 years ago
on a dark Caribbean night I'm standing
on the crumpled hood of a car
Bleeding Out
my friend
when I just wrecked a car he's screaming
at top of his lungs he's bleeding we
know if we're gonna live and I'm
standing on this car
looking down all this blood and I'm in
Terror
and I just remember looking down the
hood and just thinking
did I even matter
you know
and I hated the answer at that time in
life
because that 19 year old kid I didn't
know about impact Theory
for real I didn't know to think about
that you some you know young kids
sometimes they don't know to think about
that I didn't know to think about
Legacy meaning
did I matter I didn't think I did
but the good news is I'm a good learner
and I felt like I got a second chance
from God that night and I learned
that it was really important for me to
figure out how do I live and how do I
love and how do I matter in such a way
that if I face my death again I'll know
I've earned the second chance
and so what I want to tell people and
the impact I want is I just want people
to know know your questions Man live
intentionally and earn the life that
you've been given because This Moment's
a blessing so earn this moment and live
intentionally
angry all the time you gotta change how
you look at the world
there's a lot in the news that can piss
you off yes there's a lot going on that
causes outrage all day long on Twitter
or social media somewhere but if that's
your sole Focus no wonder you're upset
all the time lots of people are angry
right now because of the news or
something chaotic or terrible or
something they don't agree with is
happening in the world but that's not
new there's always chaos there's always
turmoil there's always bad things happen
in the world but if that's your focus no
wonder you're having that anxiety and
that frustration and that anger all the
time you got to change both your focus
and how you're reacting to things when
you do see it so first let's work on
your focus you know our as much as
you're angry all the time are you also
noticing the beauty of this world I mean
the odds that you're even alive and
having your breath is something to
connect to every single morning to have
reverence for your life in the morning
to wake up in one of my late mentors was
Wayne Dyer an amazing amazing teacher
and he always talked about how he woke
up he rolled over he put his feet on the
ground and he said thank you
thank you thank you he was grateful for
his day and he began that way and I
think so many people right now they kind
of roll up in bed and they're like and
they grab their freaking phone and they
start going through the news on social
media and what are they queuing
immediately I'm cueing stress chaos
turmoil clickables you know it's like
clickbait click clickbait clickbait no
wonder you're frustrated you're
activating your brain immediately right
off the beginning of the day in all the
turmoil of the world put the dang phone
down get up and think about what you're
grateful for about what you want to
achieve and give and serve and create
that day about who needs you to be on
your A game that day so you can focus on
that instead of like this in bed that
will change how you start your day and
then listen a lot of people who are
angry all the time they're also in
Outrage all the time because they're
focusing on the problem all the time and
they're bemoaning the problem they're
calling out the problem complaining
about the problem judging criticizing
getting upset all the time a ton of
people who stay in anger all the time
are failing to be solution based
that's what they're doing right they're
just anger anger problem problem outrage
outrage outrage but listen when you
become a solution-based person you say
okay I actually want to do something
about this problem and you start taking
positive steps to at least address it or
to participate suddenly that anger goes
into a new fire and that fire is called
enthusiasm it is easy to switch anger
into enthusiasm when you become solution
based as a mindset when you say okay I
don't like this let me do something let
me let me call somebody let me take this
action let me write that letter let me
send that email let me get my friends
together let's go protest let's go get
involved let's participate because
participation turns anger often into
enthusiasm and so if you're just stewing
on the things you don't like of course
it's going to be a negative energy but
if you start stewing on the things that
you can do you find personal power you
find enthusiasm you find Social
contribution ultimately you find
Community because one reason it's so
easy to be angry is when you're alone
you're at home you're sort of thinking
and thinking and thinking and thinking
about all the negative things and you
don't have an outlet of other human
beings to discuss with especially
solution-oriented people or people with
ideas and dreams and Ambitions people
who are doing stuff with their life
because listen when you're on a path of
purpose you ain't got time for drama
I don't have time for a ton of anger in
my life because I'm too busy making
positive changes that's where we want to
get you we want to shift your attention
and focus in the morning we want to
start making you more solution based and
get your community of people around who
are ambitious and driven to change and
to make positive change happen when we
do that the anger starts going away and
if you can't get over the anger yourself
then don't be shy about asking for help
you know a lot of people they don't have
anybody to talk to so I'm like get a
therapist man get in a group man talk
with some people go to a seminar getting
a new sort of environment you want to
get rid of the anger go volunteer get
around other people who are making
positive impacts that community that
shift changes your life you don't have
to be angry anymore and the last part
about that is Letting Go
you got to let go of those things that
upset you three years ago five years ago
ten years ago if you're an adult and
you're still
still angry and pissed pissed things
that happen to you and why
and I say that with all sincerity and
all respect if you're having mental
thoughts that are coming from a place
that are literally based 5 10 20 years
ago that you just didn't deal with yet
you need help dealing with it and you
need to get yourself a meditation
practice or a therapist or into some
kind of way that you're on a consistent
basis letting things go here's what I do
every Sunday I go okay what was I pissed
about this last week what really
bothered me okay I gotta let that go
because you can't keep charging into the
next week angry from last week you got
to let it go you got to find a clean
slate for yourself so that your your
soul can expand and can be positive and
can be ambitious and motivated and
serving the next week because listen
anger after anger after anger hatred
after hatred after hatred criticism
after criticism after criticism
rejection after rejection after
rejection outrage after outrage after
outrage it weighs you down
so you've got to change how much of that
you're taking in and you've got to make
sure every single week you're doing some
kind of like mental detox to let that
stuff go and instead of cultivating the
anger cultivate the Gratitude cultivate
the enthusiasm and you can change your
life if you want another amazing Brendan
burchard clip check it out right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there